sáng 14. Một tại quân viên báo nhân dân, bây mốt hàng chống Hà Nội đã diễn ra
trên lắm hành động vì cộng đồng 2 ngàn khu trọng 2 milam với chủ đề,
kiên chỉ phục xưa. Chỉnh lắm hành động vì cộng đồng 2 ngàn khu trọng 2 milam
giới thiệu 2 mil bài giữ an, sáng kến xuất sắc lọt vào vòng Trung Két,
mối giữ an là một câu chuyện về lòng kên định, tinh thành bên bì và ý chỉ phục xưa con người.
Thế hiện những nỗ lực trong sáo dục, ý tế, mối chường, văn hoa, chuyển đầu xanh và mình đàn xáo hội.
Thông qua không dàn trường bài trực quan, két nối trực tiếp với phố đi bộ hồ gơm,
trên lắm hướng đến việc lắm toạ cảm hướng hành động,
khuyến khích mỗi người dân cùng trong tay kiến tạo một Việt Nam nhân ảy bệnh vẫn.
Mối giữ an, nếu có một câu chuyện dân, nhưng tiêu trung lại,
đều là những lỗi lực đáng chân trọng, những sáng kến đáng hợp hỏi,
những môi hình đáng được nhân dọc, đề hợp đồng tại Việt Nam,
được kiến tạo vì một tiêu lắm toạ và bệnh vẫn hơn.
Trong quân viên trường bài, bán tổ chất đã chia chìa lắm thành môi cục chủ đe,
vườn sức sống xanh, những dự án bảo vệ môi trường,
mặc môn tự hào, những dự án bảo vệ dìm giữ và phát vươi dí xanh.
Vứng văn lôi trình nhỏ, những dự án bảo vệ và trăm sóc trẻ em,
vì cuộc sống tốt đẹp của người Việt.
Vịt Nam một nhà, những dự án bảo vệ sinh mạng và hỗ trợ đời sống cho nhân dân.
Sống đời dự rớ, những dự án xuống người yếu thế quên lên trong cuộc sống,
cậm đồng thiệt vận, các dự án cậm đồng trung tại tương thân tương ái,
cùng nào vườn lên, kiến tạo một cuộc sống thiệt vận.
Tại trẻ, vong đời mối của tài nguyên, các dự án tại trẻ vừa bảo vệ môi trường sống,
vừa có hiệu quả kinh tế cao.
Lâm sâu tự đất mẹ, các dự án nông nhập bệnh vẫn,
bảo vệ sức khỏe môi trường và nân cao tù nhập cho cậm đồng.
Gến tạo kiện miên xanh, các dự án, gến tạo đời sống khỏe mạnh trong lạnh,
xin trào tương lai, các dự án mở giá tương lai mới cho tự hệ trẻ, giúp họ hoàn yp,
và nằm bắt được những vận hội mới.
Chỉnh làm xin giá tương lai mới làm, đến nay 3 mươi thống mề môi,
năm 2 ngàn không trong 2 mươi làm,
tại quên viên bảo nân dân, kết nối trực tiếp vệ phố đi bộ hộ gơm.